the Cambridge's had arrived for their
first official visit to Ireland here on
a subtle charm offensive deployed by the
British government help smooth over
tensions caused by brexit president
Michael D Higgins and his wife were
ready to give them a warm welcome a man
committed to reconciliation he invited
William and Kate to ring the peace Bell
[Applause]
but a visit the Garden of Remembrance in
the center of Dublin was most symbolic
[Music]
as the couple bowed their heads to
remember those who lost their lives
fighting for Irish independence from
British rule it was only in 2011 that
the Queen made her first historic visit
nine years on her grandson wrote may we
never forget the lessons of history or
we continue to build a brighter future
Bobbie McDonough who was Islands
ambassador to the UK during the Queen's
visit I think a state visit or a visit
by a member of the royal family is at a
level above politics so it doesn't alter
the politics it doesn't solve the
problems that remain to be solved but it
does remind us that at a very profound
level there is a deep friendship between
Britain and Ireland in recent years we
have seen the Cambridge's picking up
more of these diplomatic elite sensitive
tours and engagements which is only to
be expected for a future king and queen
but it is likely that there are going to
be more expectations on their time as
others step back from their royal duties
Island was Harry and Megan's first tour
after they got married on Thursday Megan
is back in the UK for the first time
since they announced they want their new
life which means an unfortunate clash
with the end of the Cambridge's tour and
half the press pack heading home early
as William and Kate will continue to woo
this Irish crowd Rhiannon Mills Sky News
in Dublin